Kevin you you moved recently and I heard
the the random show you did with Tim
recently were you talking about getting
rid of one thing a day that's right and
and and I don't think the Skinner the
active game or the stuff
brings you sort of long-term happiness
or contentment or well-being but I think
it's an important first step for many of
us right where it's like this stuff has
gotten in the way right and so it seems
to me like when you were talking about
letting go of one thing a day it wasn't
because I mean yeah you you sort of feel
this weight lifted right away sure but
that is merely the first step it's
making room for what is more important
you spending time with your daughter or
your family or I mean when I come into
your house which is a relatively new
house I feel a sense of calm people
often associate like tiny house living
with with minimalism and that's one side
of it yeah but that's never been as
appealing to to me personally because it
that I think the better question is like
what not what is the how many square
feet or your house is like what's the
appropriate amount of space for me and
my family right we have a way to
architect and our documentary is a
minimalist architect is a mess Frank and
one of the things that I was asking him
about was how does he go about building
a house for someone he said I never
asked people do you want a living room
do you want three bedrooms do you want a
three-car garage do you want a dining
room because people to say yes to
everything I'm supposed to have this he
said instead I asked people how they
live their life and I try to build a
house around that because if I don't do
that you're just gonna cram someone
else's life into that house right you
know trying to fill every corner sort of
thing and then 5 10 15 20 years from now
you look around you realize like I've
got all this stuff the average American
household has 300 thousand items in it
that's insane and and I don't it doesn't
happen overnight and I think the same
thing is true with the simplifying that
simplifying thing doesn't happen
overnight either that's why I like the
idea of you you're gaining momentum
because getting rid of one item a day
turns very quickly into
you know what like I've got this
momentum now I can get rid of ten things
today or yeah and it also helps you kind
of reframe in your head when you're
about to make another purchase you're
like is this something I'm gonna have to
eventually give away because it's a bad
purchase right what's the true cost of
the thing yeah we often think of the
price tag is the cost but it's like
taking care of the thing worrying about
the thing that has a psychological way
putting fuel in the thing changing the
things batteries changing the oil and
the thing cleaning the thing there's
like all of these extra costs that we
don't think about the at the point of
sale yeah that's right the other thing
too about letting go or practising
letting go like one thing per day late
that gives you the ability to let go of
more things and like the the biggest I
think superpower that Josh and I have
been able to gain from from this life
that we've live in the last you know 10
years
you